[Music]
well all week as you may know we've had
a blast launching ridiculous objects
across
the open span
of chicago state street drawbridge okay
that's just what you do with a
drawbridge right why not you shoot crap
over it absolutely
well we want to do our uh last bridge
jump tonight and uh we wanted um we want
to do something a little special i think
it's very special check this out
it's a scale model of the millennium
park bean
but we actually filled it with baked
beans
there it is
the bean first appeared in chicago's
monument park in 2006.
it's made of stainless steel we've
stuffed it with chicago style baked
beans it weighs
over 650 pounds the bridge is up it is
the most aerodynamic object we have
launched yet
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
thank god
usa usa
hi
i've never been prouder of this country
you know it has been
an amazing week
of bridge jumps let's take just a quick
look back
at all the action
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes
you